- [Voiceover] Here.
(playful music, featuring a trumpet)
- Mars and I have been
cat human buddies for
about five years now.
He's just this, he's
the biggest stoner cat.
He just loves to sit around, eat,
he loves being in bags,
I don't know what to say,
he just loves being in bags.
- This is my cat Riceball,
he's very friendly, he's
more like a dog cat,
He like, he does not afraid of people,
he doesn't scratch, or anything.
No, he has never been outside before,
but when I moved out to LA,
I did brought him with me,
but he's never been actually,
physically on the ground.
- My name in Rocco, and I love cats.
More than I could love anything else.
My first adult job,
being a cat care attendant at the SPCA,
and moved into cat behavior specialist
at the San Francisco SPCA.
This guy is like, the most
special cat I've ever met.
I just was realizing
that I wouldn't sell him
for a million dollars.
I think the benefits of
walking a cat on a leash
is that they do get that outdoor time,
but then there's no chance that
they're going to get mauled
or carried away by a coyote.
I would say the first
piece of advice I have,
not all cats are gonna take to a harness.
- [Devin] Can you stay still for a second?
Stay still. No.
- So right now I'm trying
to put the leash on him.
- I'm not hurting my cat, I promise,
I'm just kind of making him do something
that is good for him ultimately.
- [Iris] Riceball thank you!
But you have to come back!
- If your cat freezes in the harness,
then you're going to have to work on
its relationship to
being inside that harness
before you can take it outside.
- So, I had to call in backup,
this is my roommate Abby,
we are going to attempt
to put this on him.
Yay, the harness is on!
- Oh, but you look so cute in this!
- He doesn't look happy, does he?
- [Abby] No, no, that's not
a happy cat right there.
- [Devin] He does not look happy.
- Okay, I heard you.
- The best advice with any type
of behavioral issue with a cat
is try to figure out
how to work with them.
Because if it knows you want something,
it's not going to do it.
So if you want them to do something,
then you're gonna have to
figure out how to trick them
into thinking that they want it.
- What is this? Look at it! Oh! Oh!
He's walking with me!
- Here we go!
Let's try this.
No, let's go this way.
(Mars meows)
Mars!
- [Iris] Let's go, let's go.
Let's go, treat!
- [Devin] Mars, c'mon.
C'mon baby.
We're just gonna go,
no, we're just gonna go on a little walk.
- (laughing) Look at her!
- He's stressing me out,
I'm really, this is really stressful.
This is very, very stressful.
Uh, he's not liking this, at all.
- Oh he's, he's doing
better than I thought.
I thought he was just gonna,
like, sitting in one corner,
and doesn't move at all.
But he's making some kind of process.
C'mon, let's go!
- Mars is now wedged in
between my neighbors hedge
and my front porch.
- We probably walked, like,
three steps out of apartment?
The apartment door is right there.
- I just feel like maybe
this wasn't for him.
Right? You wanna go back inside?
- And cats, we're built to serve them.
That's why the ancient
Egyptian's worshipped them,
you know what I mean?
I live to serve my cat, and that's honest.
So, if he wants to go on a walk,
I'm gonna provide that service.